sur public sénat bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver sur public sénat pour
leur dernière séance mardi 6 mars 2012
avant à la suspension des travaux
parlementaires pour cause de campagne
pour l'élection présidentielle
les sénateurs ont adopté une proposition
de résolution européenne sur le
traitement des données à caractère
personnel
il faut dire que bruxelles veut mettre
en place une législation européenne en
la matière
une proposition vise en effet à imposer
aux grands groupes de l'internet ce
d'obtenir sous peine d'amendé le
consentement préalable des personnes
pour l'utilisation de leurs données
personnelles
mais pour la cnil la commission
nationale informatique et libertés en
france ce serait une régression car les
plaintes des internautes ne seraient pas
traités par l'autorité de contrôle du
pays de résidence de l'internaute
mais par le pays dans lequel se trouve
l'entreprise visée retour donc ce matin
sur cette séance bonne matinée à tous
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
président mes chers collègues l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de résolution européenne
présentée en application de l'article 73
15 pièces du règlement sur la
proposition de règlement du parlement
européen et du conseil relatif à la
protection des personnes physiques à
l'égard du traitement des données à
caractère personnel et la libre
circulation de ces données dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur simon sutour auteur de la
proposition de résolution rapporteur de
la commission des lois est rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des affaires
européennes vous avez la parole monsieur
le président merci monsieur le président
je crois que c'est un moment important
parce que cette proposition de
résolution
européenne est importante par ce sujet
la protection des données personnelles
je crois aussi que c'est une première
dans notre assemblée après le vote de
notre nouveau nouveau règlement il y a
maintenant quelques mois pour ne pas
dire quelques années où on a la
possibilité pour une proposition de
résolution de partir de la commission au
fond la commission des lois la
commission européenne pour avis et un
vote en séance publique du sénat pour
donner plus de solennité à notre prise
de position ce qui pèsera dans le débat
européen en tant qu'opposition en
parlement national donc monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le 25 janvier dernier la
commission européenne a présenté deux
textes qui procède à une refonte
complète du cadre européen de la
protection des données personnelles
une proposition de règlement européen
une proposition de directive
la proposition de règlement concerne les
fichiers privés et commerciaux et la
proposition de directive les fichiers
dits de souveraineté utilisés notamment
dans le cadre des procédures pénales
le 8 février en application de l'article
73 15 pièces notre règlement auquel je
viens de faire allusion
la commission des lois décidé de se
saisir de ces deux textes
de son côté la commission des affaires
européennes s'en est saisi pour avis
j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été nommés à la
fois rapportée aux formes pour la
commission des lois est rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des affaires
européennes
merci monsieur le président et j'ai le
plaisir de vous annoncer ou de vous
confirmer que nos deux commissions
partagent la même analyse
ces deux textes devant être adoptés sur
la procédure législative ordinaire
c'est-à-dire par codécision entre le
parlement européen et le conseil de
l'union européenne le processus de
négociation entamé va durer quelques
temps compte tenu des brefs délais qui
sont les nôtres et des problématiques
différentes abordés par ces deux textes
la proposition de résolution soumise à
votre examen ne porte que sur la
proposition de règlement
relatifs aux fichiers privés et
commerciaux
mais je souhaite qu'ultérieurement nous
traitions du problème de la directive
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir par la
suite en effet sur ces sujets et
particulièrement sur la proposition de
directive relative aux fichiers de
souveraineté comme je vous l'indiquais
nous la laissons aujourd'hui deux côtés
parallèlement à la présente proposition
de résolution qui s'adresse au
gouvernement la commission des affaires
européennes a déposé le 23 février
dernier sur le fondement de l'article 73
acte thiès de notre règlement une
proposition de résolution adressée cette
fois directement aux institutions
européennes portant avis motivé sur la
conformité aux principes de subsidiarité
de la proposition de règlement
ce texte est devenu résolution du sénat
le 4 mars 2012
après son adoption par la commission des
lois commission compétente au forum
la proposition de résolution qui vous
est soumise aujourd'hui vise
exclusivement la proposition de
règlement européen relatif aux fichiers
privés aux commerciaux elle a vocation à
remplacer la directive de 1995 très
largement inspiré de la législation
française pionnière en la matière ce
texte marque en son temps une avancée
décisive
je crois que ce que nous sommes
pionniers n'avons pas honte à avoir à le
souligner cependant de l'avis général et
les personnes que j'ai entendus en
audition me l'ont confirmé
il est aujourd'hui nécessaire de
franchir une nouvelle étape en matière
de protection européenne de données
personnelles et ce pour trois raisons la
première c'est que la directive de 1995
n'a pas permis une harmonisation
suffisante de la protection des données
personnelles dans les états membres
ainsi par exemple jusqu'en 2011
l'autorité de contrôle britannique ne
disposer d'aucun pouvoir de sanctions
contre les responsables de traitement
la deuxième raison est le caractère
obsolète de la directive la révolution
des nouvelles technologies l'explosion
d'internet
la multiplication et la place toujours
plus
important des réseaux sociaux
l'indexation massive des contenus
publiés en ligne sont autant d'éléments
qui accroissent considérablement le
volume des données personnelles
collectées et changer ainsi que les
possibilités de leur consultation de
leur exploitation à des fins notamment
commerciales
enfin la dernière raison qui justifie
une révision de la législation
communautaire tient à
l'internationalisation croissante des
transferts de données entre les états
membres de l'union européenne même mais
aussi entre les états membres et les
états tiers à l'union européenne
le régulateur national ne peut plus agir
seul nous devons unir nos forces et dans
notre droit pour imposer notamment aux
états non européens
le respect des règles de protection des
données des citoyens européens
la commission européenne s'est saisie de
ce dossier
elle a appelé dans une communication de
novembre 2010 à une approche globale
pour la protection des données
personnelles en europe
la proposition de règlement constitue
l'aboutissement de ces travaux et donc
conduire selon elle à une harmonisation
de droit applicable sur le modèle des
droits les plus avancés en la matière
c'est ce que nous a indiqué notamment la
vice présidente de la commission
européenne madame reding
lorsque nous l'avons auditionné il y a
quelques jours
l'heure est décisive en effet le texte
qui nous est présenté une proposition de
règlement nous n'aurons plus en
connaître une fois adopté conforme à ce
qui se passe pour une directive où je
dirait monsieur le ministre ce qui
devrait se passer pour une transposition
de directive car de plus en plus le
parlement ne les voit pas les
transpositions de directives mais c'est
un autre sujet sur lequel nous aurons à
intervenir ultérieurement si nous
voulons peser c'est maintenant dans la
phase de négociation qu'il faut agir
il est essentiel sur un sujet qui engage
autant les droits fondamentaux de la
personne que la représentation nationale
se fassent entendre
la proposition de règlement prévoit un
certain nombre d'améliorations dans le
texte qui vous est présentée prend acte
elle prévoit notamment que le
consentement de la personne à
l'utilisation de ces données
personnel devra être exprès elle
reconnaît aux internautes en droit la
portabilité de leurs données qui leur
permettra de s'affranchir de l'autorité
de traitement sans perdre usage de leurs
données elle réaffirme le droit
d'opposition de chacun au traitement de
ses données personnelles et encadre
strictement la possibilité pour les
responsables de traitement de soumettre
les données qu'ils ont recueillies à un
profilage informatique
elle consacre un droit à l'oubli
numérique permettant à chacun d'obtenir
l'effacement des données personnelles
qui lui porte préjudice
la proposition de règlement propose de
nouvelles règles d'autorisation des
fichiers qui repose notamment pour les
fichiers les plus sensibles sur
l'obligation de les soumettre à une
étude d'impact
elle modifie la réglementation relative
au transfert de données vers des pays
tiers l'union européenne parallèlement
le texte fait peser sur les responsables
de traitement des obligations nouvelles
comme la désignation d'un délégué à la
protection des données dans les
entreprises de plus de 250 salariés ou
le renforcement des sanctions contre les
entreprises ne respectant pas les règles
fixées
la proposition de règlement adapte aussi
le système de contrôle des responsables
de traitement en créant notamment un
comité européen de la protection des
données auxquelles sera associé le
contrôleur européen de la protection des
données qui se substituera à l'actuel
groupe de travail réunissant les cnil
européennes dit groupe de l'article 29
où j'ai 29
cette proposition de règlement contient
donc de réelles avancées par rapport est
le communautaire en vigueur
certaines comme l'exigence du
consentement exprès le droit
d'opposition une rectification ou le
statut d'indépendance et les pouvoirs de
l'autorité de contrôle existent
cependant déjà dans notre droit national
d'autres consacre des évolutions
attendues
je tiens à cet égard à rendre hommage au
travail perdent précurseur de nos
collègues ici présents yves détraigne et
anne-marie escoffier qui dans leur
rapport d'information sur la vie privée
à l'heure du numérique
puis dans la proposition de loi issue de
leurs travaux et rap
porté par notre éminent collègue
christian cointat on présentait
certaines évolutions aujourd'hui
consacrés par la proposition de
règlement comme la reconnaissance du
droit à l'oubli
ce qui n'est pas rien ou l'obligation de
désignation de délégués à la protection
des données
on ne peut que regretter monsieur le
ministre que cette proposition de loi
adoptée à l'unanimité au sénat
il ya presque deux ans n'est jamais été
examiné par l'assemblée nationale
et oui malgré ces avancées notables
le dispositif proposé présente de vraies
lacunes qu'il revient au sénat de
dénoncer la présente proposition de
résolution entend par conséquent attiré
l'attention du gouvernement sur ces
lacunes
au moment où les négociations s'engagent
la proposition de règlement doit tout
d'abord aller plus loin sur certains
points sur le droit à l'oubli et les
moteurs de recherche
et puis je m'adresse à mes collègues
détraigne et anne-marie escoffier sur le
statut juridique de l'adresse ip ou sur
l'encadrement des transferts
internationaux de données sur la
désignation obligatoire d'un délégué à
la protection des données ainsi que sur
le renforcement des pouvoirs des
autorités de contrôle nationales
sur ce dernier point j'indique qu'à
l'initiative de notre collègue jean paul
amoudry et plusieurs de ses collègues du
groupe de l'union centriste et
républicaine
la proposition de résolution appelle le
gouvernement à faire preuve de la plus
grande vigilance monsieur le ministre
quant à l'encadrement trop restrictif
des pouvoirs d'investigation des
autorités de contrôle nationales
j'en viens maintenant au coeur de la
proposition de résolution qui est
soumise à votre examen les deux
questions de principe que pose le texte
de la commission européenne la première
question porte sur la marge que conserve
le législateur national pour adopter des
dispositions nationales plus protectrice
la commission a fait le choix d'une
proposition de règlement plutôt qu'une
proposition de guy directives afin de
garantir une harmonisation complète des
législations et lorsqu'il y
harmonisation
évidemment il est souhaitable qu'elle
soit par l'eau et non pas par le bas
nous sommes là au coeur dessus du sujet
une question fondamentale se pose donc
pour les états comme la france dans la
législation en matière de protection des
données personnelles est souvent
pionnière il ya le lait à la matière la
protection apportée par ce texte
constituera tel un plafond ou un
plancher serait il envisageable qu'en
élevant le niveau moyen de protection
apportée à l'ensemble des citoyens
européens
le règlement diminue celle d'en
bénéficier ceux qui résidaient dans un
état membre qui avait fait le choix de
garanties complémentaires
lors de son audition par la commission
des lois et la commission des affaires
européennes le 21 février dernier
madame reding commissaire européenne en
charge de ce dossier nous a indiqué
clairement qu'elle entendait faire
respecter le principe un continent une
règle elle nous a même indiqué que nous
étions elle était entre nos mains mais
nous avons plutôt eu le sentiment que
nous étions parfois entre les siennes or
la protection des données personnelles
participe de la protection de la vie
privée que le conseil constitutionnel
rattache à la liberté individuelle
mentionnés à l'article 2 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen cet ancrage constitutionnel de
la protection des données personnelles
justifie cas le prime toutes les autres
considérations notamment les
considérations économiques que la
commission européenne met en avant pour
limiter les garanties apportées aux
personnes
la présente proposition de résolution
européenne invite donc le gouvernement
français monsieur le ministre à veiller
à ce que l'harmonisation s'effectue sans
préjudice de la possibilité pour les
états membres ont adopté des
dispositions plus favorables à la
protection des données
cela suppose notamment de mentionner
expressément dans le règlement de telles
possibilités de dérogation dans le sens
du mieux disant
j'observe par ailleurs que la
proposition de règlement ne parvient
même pas à définir avec suffisamment de
précision le cadre légal qu'elle met en
place ceux ci se manifeste
et cela nous inquiète par laurent voix
près de 50 fois dans le texte un des
actes délégués ou à des actes
d'exécution adoptée par le collège des
commissaires pour préciser les modalités
d'application du règlement
toutes les personnes que j'ai entendu on
critiquer ce renvoi massif à la
législation des ligues la proposition de
résolution insiste sur la nécessité de
veiller à ce que les compétences
normative des législateurs européens et
nationaux ou celles des régulateurs
nationaux ne soit pas ici à abandonner à
la seule compétence de la commission
européenne la résolution du sénat pour
un avis motivé sur la conformité aux
principes de subsidiarité de la
proposition de règlement que j'évoquais
précédemment qui a été adopté par la
commission des affaires européennes
insiste particulièrement sur ce point le
texte pose une deuxième question de
principe c'est celle qui a le plus
focalisés la tasse l'attention de notre
cnil et sur laquelle sa présidente avait
souhaité alerter la commission des lois
lors de sono mis son audition dès
novembre dernier il s'agit du dispositif
du guichet unique proposée par la
commission européenne qui attribue la
compétence pour instruire les requêtes
des citoyens européens à l'autorité de
contrôle du pays dans lequel
responsables de traitement en cause à
son principal établissement
l'objectif avoué de ce dispositif est de
faciliter les démarches administratives
des entreprises qui n'auront plus qu'un
interlocuteur unique à l'échelle
européenne
cependant il est paradoxal que le
citoyen soit moins bien traités
j'insiste là dessus
il est paradoxal que le citoyen soit
moins bien traités que l'entreprise
responsable du traitement en est à lui
privé de la possibilité de voir
l'ensemble de ces plaintes instruites
par son autorité de contrôle national or
il me semble que lorsqu'il s'agit
d'assurer la meilleure protection du
citoyen et son droit à un recours
effectif
il convient comme en matière de
consommation de privilégier la solution
qui permet à l'intéressé de s'adresser à
l'autorité la plus proche de lui
et auprès de laquelle il a l'habitude
d'accomplir ses démarches
un autre sans même évoquer le risque de
forum shopping dénoncé par la cnil le
dispositif du guichet unique présente de
multiples inconvénients il pose la
question des moyens de l'autorité de
contrôle national par exemple
l'autorité irlandaise où est installé
facebook disposera-t-elle des moyens
suffisants pour faire face à l'afflux de
contention provenance des autres pays
européens
il crée une asymétrie pour le plaignant
entre les recours administratifs exercer
auprès de l'autorité étrangères dont
dépend le principal établissement du
responsable de traitement et les recours
juridictionnel portée devant le juge
national
la commission a certes prévu des
aménagements au principe du guichet
unique
elle propose un mécanisme de
coordination entre autorités de contrôle
et prévoit que l'autorité nationale se
charge de la transmission de la plaine
talent autorités étrangères
ces expédients sont cependant
insuffisant le citoyen se voit à la fois
privé de la possibilité de voir sa
demande instruite par l'autorité de
contrôle qui est lui et qui lui est la
plus proche et la plus accessible et
privés de la possibilité de se voir
appliquer les dispositions de droit
nationales plus favorable c'est pourquoi
la proposition de résolution appelle le
gouvernement à veiller dans la
négociation qui s'ouvre à ce que le
critère du principal établissement soit
abandonnée au profit du principe selon
lequel autorités de contrôle compétentes
et celle du pays de résidence de
l'intéressé
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
tel est le sens de la proposition de
résolution européenne que la commission
des lois unanime vous propose d'adopter
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole à monsieur jean
pierre sueur président de la commission
des lois
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
permettez moi tout d'abord de me réjouir
de l'excellente coopération qui existe
on l'a vu encore ce matin lors de notre
réunion de la commission des lois
entre la commission des affaires
européennes et son président simon
sutour qui vient de s'exprimer et nos
collègues de la commission des lois le
fait que nous puissions travailler très
efficacement ensemble et je crois très
positif pour la pertinence et la clarté
des avis et résolution que nous sommes
amenés mes chers collègues à vous
proposer
je voudrais aborder succinctement quatre
points jeudi succinctement car comme
simon sutour a déjà éloquemment aborder
ces sujets je ne voudrais pas allonger
inutilement le propos premier point il y
a des droits individuels qui sont très
importants je pense au droit à l'oubli
et il est bien que le projet de
règlement européenne y fasse allusion et
que nous disions dans la résolution que
cela est un bienfait en effet nous
connaissons tous des jeunes en
particulier ou de moins jeunes qui
peuvent être poursuivis des années
durant
parce que telle publication à leur insu
le plus souvent est parue sur un site
internet il est très important que l'on
respecte la vie privée et respecter la
vie privée
cela veut dire
prendre les moyens et je partage aussi
ce qui a été dit sur le rapport de
madame escoffier de monsieur détraigne
prendre les moyens pour faire en sorte
que chacun à tout moment puisse
préserver et garantir son intimité ou ce
qui pour lui relève de son intimité
il s'agit là d'un droit de la personne
ce droit à l'oubli que nous devons
défendre parce que les conséquences
peuvent être extrêmement lourdes et
dommageable
second point nous devons être très
vigilants quant à la question de savoir
si le droit européen va se caler sur ce
qui offre le plus de garanties le pays
qui offre le plus de garanties dans les
différentes législations européennes
aussi on va chercher à créer une sorte
de plus petit des nattes dénominateur
commun qui serait préjudiciable à des
pays comme la france et à des citoyens
comme les citoyens français qui peuvent
saisir la cnil dont nous savons nous
avons reçu sa présidente qu'elle fait
autorité eux au plan national mais aussi
au plan européen puisque beaucoup de
travail a été fait depuis des années au
sein de la cnil pour garantir nos
libertés à cet égard lorsque la question
a été posée ici même lors de l'audition
de madame reding
la question de savoir si l'harmonisation
serait un plafond interdisant toutes
dispositions nationales plus favorables
ou bien un plancher comme en matière de
consommation par exemple madame reding a
indiqué je la cite non
il n'y aura pas de niveau de protection
différentes différents c'est l'essence
même d'un règlement une loi identique
pour tout le territoire de l'union
européenne
j'ai retenu les règles les plus
protectrices des systèmes existants et
bien la suite nous montrera que non en
particulier par rapport à cette question
de l'établissement principal
alors je vous rappeler que la protection
des données personnelles relèvent du
champ des droits fondamentaux et que le
conseil constitutionnel considère que la
protection de la vie privée fait partie
des libertés individuelles fondamentales
mentionnés à l'article 2 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen nous considérons nous à la
commission des lois
en total accord avec la commission des
affaires européennes que cet ancrage
constitutionnel justifie que la liberté
personnelle la protection des données
personnelles
la protection de la vie privée prime sur
les autres considérations
c'est pourquoi nous demandons instamment
au gouvernement de la république jeudi
au gouvernement en place au gouvernement
futur est mais j'ai vu d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre que eux l'un des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
avait justement fait des propositions
qui ont dû vous intéressé par rapport à
la désignation du ministre de la justice
non je je je je soutiens françois
hollande monsieur mercier
je me permets de le dire publiquement au
cas où certains auraient pu en douter
donc je veux dire que pour nous ce qui
touche aux droits les plus fondamentaux
de la personne ou à la protection du
faible contre le fort
eh bien
pour cela la construction européenne n'a
de sens que si elles élèvent la
protection commune sans interdire les
pros les progrès pour mieux promue par
certains états membres avant que les
autres les rejoignent plus tard donc
nous appelons le gouvernement à y
veiller
personne ne comprendrait monsieur le
ministre que le règlement européen se
traduisent par un moins par rapport à ce
qui existe aujourd'hui en france quant à
la protection des libertés publiques
delà des libertés personnelles et de la
vie privée
troisième point la question de la gesse
législation délégué la proposition de
règlement renvoi près d'une cinquantaine
de fois nous l'avons nous avons compté à
des actes délégués ou à des actes
d'exécution adopté par la commission
européenne pour compléter la législation
européenne le nombre et l'importance de
ces renvois pose un problème de
subsidiarité puisqu'il confère tellement
de pouvoir à la commission qu'on vient à
penser que c'est qu'au détriment du
législateur européen et des législateurs
nationaux et aussi les autorités de
contrôle nationales comme la cnil
notre proposition de résolution en fait
état cette question est aussi traitée
par la proposition de résolution portant
avis motivé sur la subsidiarité qui a
été présenté à juste titre par la
commission des affaires européennes
enfin j'arrive au dernier point qui est
très sensible qui a été évoquée
également par simon sutour qui est la
question du lycée unique parlons très
clair à partir du moment où le règlement
établirait que le droit qui s'applique
les instances compétentes les types de
la cnil serait celle du pays où se
trouve l'établissement principal d'un
site
eh bien il pourrait y avoir un grave
problème pour la défense de nos libertés
exemple concret si tel site je pense à
google ou à facebook que tout le monde
connaît avait son siège en irlande
et bien si l'on suivait le projet de
règlement ce serait le droit irlandais
qui s'appliquerait nous n'avons rien
contre le droit irlandais mais il se
trouve qu'il est avéré que notre droit
est beaucoup plus protecteur des
libertés individuelles des libertés
publiques et de la vie privée
à partir de ce moment là il se passerait
que pour tous les citoyens de l'europe
là le droit se raidit par le droit de
tel ou tel pays en l'espèce l'irlande
ce serait je crois incompréhensible cela
pourrait se traduire par une déperdition
inacceptable et c'est pourquoi nous
demandons au gouvernement français de
veiller tout particulièrement à ce que
cela ne puisse se traduire dans le
règlement j'ajoute qu'il y aurait là une
disparité total est incompréhensible
en effet ce dispositif aboutirait
paradoxalement dans un tête dans un
texte dont on nous dit que l'objet
principal est d'élever le niveau des
bénévoles de la protection des données
personnelles
cela reviendrait à traités plus
favorablement le responsable de
traitement que le citoyen puisque
le responsable du traitement tel ou tel
site qui a un grand succès et bien
pourrait choisir le droit en vertu
duquel il serait jugé
alors que pour le citoyen ils devraient
obligatoirement s'adresser aux
juridictions aux instances de contrôle
de régulation d'un pays déterminé
vous voyez bien qu'il y à là quelque
chose qui n'est pas acceptable
cette dissymétrie entre les uns et les
autres
d'autant plus qu' il y a déjà eu une
disproportion réel mes chers collègues
entre les moyens des uns et des autres
s'il vous advient s'il advient que vous
ayez l'idée parce que c'est nécessaire
et parce que c'est votre droit de
citoyens de porter plainte contre l'un
des grands sites mondiaux parce que il
ya une atteinte à la vie privée parce
que il ya diffamation parce que il y as
injures et vous savez bien que ce ne
sont pas des rêves ou d utopie ou des
cauchemars c'est la réalité c'est la
réalité tous les jours il y à des
violations au respect de la vie privée
tous les jours il ya de nombreuses
violations aux droits d'auteur tous les
jours il y a des diffamations des
injures qui sont punis par la loi
alors lorsque vous êtes un citoyen un
simple citoyen et que vous avez en face
de vous une grande multinationale c'est
pas facile
si en plus il faut que vous alliez
plaidé en irlande avec un avocat qui va
se déplacer là-bas vous voyez bien que
vos droits seront ténus par rapport à
spa ce de la multinationale de
l'internet face à laquelle vous allez
vous trouver
alors nous sommes très déterminés et je
crois que monsieur sutour l'a dit je le
dis et je ne doute pas que beaucoup de
collègues 21 interviendront là dessus
nous ne pouvons pas accepter une telle
insécurité juridique
nous ne pouvons pas accepter
l'affaiblissement des garanties qui
existe aujourd'hui dans l'oeuf en
matière de libertés dans la république
française
les mécanismes de coordination prévues
par le texte ne remédie pas à
l'affaiblissement par ce dispositif du
droit du citoyen européen un recours
effectif exercer auprès de l'autorité
qui lui est la plus accessible
en l'espèce des tribunaux français où la
cnil pour les citoyens français
la proposition de résolution votée
préparé par la commission des affaires
européennes et voté des battues par la
commission des lois invite par
conséquent le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre à défendre avec fermeté
l'abandon de ce critère d'attribution de
compétences au profit de celui déjà
connu en droit de la consommation de la
compétence de l'autorité de l'état
membre où réside le plaignant je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole à
monsieur michel mercier garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice des délits et des
libertés pardon
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le président et rapporteur
simon sutour mesdames et messieurs et
les sénateurs je pourrais faire très
vite
et dire que le gouvernement est heureux
de voir que le sénat tout entier et lui
apporte renfort et soutien dans cette
question de projet de règlement européen
temps nous partageons elle même souci
d'avoir les mêmes craintes face à ce
règlement
je crois qu'il faut expliquer un peu les
choses et dire pourquoi nous ne sommes
pas satisfaits par ce projet de
règlement ce d'abord parce qu'il ya plus
de 30 ans en adoptant la loi du 6
janvier 1978 dite informatique et
libertés la france un jour été
précurseur en la matière et cette loi
qui est la pierre angulaire de la
protection des citoyens face aux
traitements de données à caractère
personnel à doter la france d'une
autorité de contrôle
la cnil elle à réglementer la manière
dont sont collectées exploiter conserver
les données personnelles par les
entreprises les administrations et les
les individus eux mêmes
pour autant le développement rapide des
nouvelles technologies posent de
nouveaux défis et des défis de taille
s'agissant de la protection des données
à caractère personnel et par conséquent
comme cela a été rapporté par dessus
tout mais également par monsieur
monsieur traite de la vie privée et des
individus internet est un vecteur sans
précédent de la liberté d'expression et
de communication le conseil
constitutionnel lui-même a eu l'occasion
dans sa décision du 10 juin 2009 de
relever l'importance prise par ces
services pour la participation à la vie
démocratique et l'expression des idées
et des opinions
mais vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le rapporteur face au
contexte de rapides mutations
technologiques dans lequel nous nous
trouvons l'effectivité du droit au
respect de la vie privée suppose
d'adapter les instruments juridiques
propres à garantir la protection des
données à caractère personnel je veux
tout d'abord rappelé que pleinement
conscients des enjeux grandissants de
cette révolution numérique
le gouvernement s'est attaché à
renforcer la protection des données
personnelles
c'est ainsi que les droits des personnes
ont été consolidées c'est notamment un
des effets de l' ordonnance du 24 août
2011 qui interdit d'installer sur
l'équipement d'un utilisateur des
logiciels qui observe sa navigation sur
internet sans en avoir informé et avoir
recueilli sonacop le même texte a
également imposé aux fournisseurs de
communications électroniques de notifier
à la commission nationale informatique
et libertés l'existence d'une faille de
sécurité
de même les moyens d'action de la cnil
ont été renforcées pour que cette
autorité de contrôle puisse disposer
pleinement des moyens propres à garantir
l'efficacité de son action au service de
la protection est des données
personnelles
le budget de la cnil a été augmentée les
moyens d'actions juridiques et de la
cnil ont été accrues la loi du 29 mars
2011 relative au défenseur des droits a
conféré à la clé d'un droit de visite
inopinée dans les locaux des
responsables de traitement droit qui est
subordonnée à l'autorisation préalable
dû juge des libertés et de la détention
afin est de garantir le respect des
droits des intéressés cette même loi
autorise par ailleurs la cnil à faire
publier les sanctions qu'elle prononce
même lorsque celles ci sont infligées
aux responsables de traitement
défaillant dans la mauvaise foi n'a pas
été établie cette publicité garantit une
meilleure connaissance par le grand
public et les organismes éventuellement
concerner des comportements susceptibles
d'être sanctionnés par la cnil
si donc des avancées ont été obtenues il
est bien évident qu'il reste encore
beaucoup à faire
précisément le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui engagée avec ses partenaires
européens dans la négociation de
nouveaux instruments communaux
terre relatif à la protection des
données personnelles la commission
européenne a rendu public le 25 janvier
dernier deux projets de textes tendant à
harmoniser sur l'ensemble du territoire
de l'union
le droit applicable à la protection des
données personnelles
le gouvernement se félicite de cette
initiative car par définition internet
dépasse les frontières des états c'est
donc d'abord au niveau européen que
doivent être redéfinies les principes
applicables en la matière pour une
effectivité plus grande des droits de
nos concitoyens
la commission a proposé un projet de
règlement applicable
positive il faut saluer la volonté de la
commission de rendre le droit européen
véritablement opposable aux opérateurs
deuxième élément positif le projet de
règlement renforce par ailleurs le
contrôle que les personnes peuvent
exercer sur leurs propres données à
caractère personnel troisième avancé
plusieurs dispositions sont de nature à
assurer un renforcement des droits des
personnes comme par exemple la
consécration du principe de consentement
préalable explicite
ceci posé d'autres aspects appel à ce
stade est de la part du gouvernement
français de fortes réserves est tout à
fait exact que nous retrouvons les deux
commissions du sénat et j'espère le
sénat lui-même et le gouvernement pour
exprimer et ses réserves
la commission tout d'abord a choisi de
proposer un règlement en lieu et place
de la directive du 24 octobre 1995
applicables aux traitements de données
personnelles
nous pensons comme de nombreux états
membres parmi lesquels l'allemagne la
finlande la suède la slovénie la
belgique l'estonie l'espagne et le
portugal que l'harmonisation proposées
par ce projet de texte serait mieux
mises en oeuvre par le biais d'une
directive détaillé laquelle permettrait
aux états membres de conserver les
spécificités de leurs législations
nationales qui se révèle sur plusieurs
points je rejoins tout à fait de ce prix
en sueur plus protectrice tu plus
protectrice pardon que le projet ait de
règlements pour revenir sur cette
question qui est absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui la loi française est plus
protectrice que ce qui est envisagé dans
le projet de règlement sur au moins
trois points
le droit d'opposition le pouvoir
contrôle des autorités nationales de
production et l'affaiblissement de père
pas conséquent des boya et d'action de
la clim est donc là une question de
principe que le gouvernement entend être
ferme
en effet un règlement européen la
vocation ni à fixer des règles minimes
ni à déterminer l objectif à atteindre
directement applicable dans l'ordre
juridique des états membres et l'exclût
toute forme de compétences nationales
dans le domaine qui tracte en réalité
l'essentiel pour nous est que le texte
européen soit suffisamment précis sont
des droits et obligations des
responsables de traitement et des
personnes concernées en revanche il
n'est pas nécessaire de rechercher
l'uniformisation du régime juridique en
la matière il n'y a notamment aucune
raison de penser de régime juridique de
protection des données constitue le
critère décisif d'investissement d'une
entreprise dans tel ou tel état membre
c'est un été le cas nous aurions déjà
constaté dans le cadre de la mise en
oeuvre de la directive 95 46 le risque
et le forum shopping ne doit ainsi pas
être surestimée en conséquence le
gouvernement considère que remplacer une
directive par règlement n'est pas la
bonne option sur le fond plusieurs
points doivent retenir notre attention
afin de ne pas amorcer de recul par
rapport aux protection apportée par
notre droit le gouvernement à l'instar
de certains états membres comme la
finlande l'irlande la suède l'italie la
slovénie l'autriche l'espagne le royaume
uni et la lituanie et de vous mêmes
messieurs et les rapporteurs des pleurs
le recours systématique excessif aux
actes délégués et osac d'exécution par
la proposition de règlement comme dans
la proposition de directive
certes comme l'a précisé madame la vice
présidente reding lors de son audition
par la commission des lois et des
affaires européennes
le recours à ces actes est liée à la
nature même du projet de texte nous
sommes toutefois convaincu car deux cas
de nombreuses reprises les précisions
nécessaires pourraient être apportées
par le règlement lui même sans qu'il
soit nécessaire de délégués à la
commission européenne le soin d'adopter
par la suite d'hôtel zag
le recours à une directive permettrait
de confier cette réglementation en tout
aux partis aux parlements nationaux afin
de mieux tenir compte des spécificités
nationales touchante aux droits et à la
protection de la vie privée comme l a
rappelé le président de commission du
doigt et le tueur constitutionnel de
cette matière de surcroît le critère du
principal établissement retenu par la
commission pour déterminer la compétence
territoriale de l'organe de contrôle
n'est pas pertinent en effet comme
certains autres où l'on souligne l lors
de l'audition de madame reding
de même d'ailleurs que les représentants
de nombreux états membres lors des deux
premières journées de travail à
bruxelles les 23 et 24 février dernier
la notion de principal établissement est
peu clair et devrait être précisée à
défaut elle donnera lieu à des
interprétations différentes selon les
états membres en outre déjà est très
important la mise en oeuvre de ce
critère éloignerait l'autorité de
protection des données est compétente du
citoyen dans les données personnelles
seraient concernés or il est d'une
particulière importance que les
personnes résidant en france puisse
s'adresser à la cnil pour les dommages
qu'ils subissent de la part de
responsables de traitement dont le
principal établissement se situe dans
d'autres pays de l'union européenne le
renforcement de l'effectivité des droits
garantis aux citoyens de l'union suppose
de le rendre plus facile d'exercice du
droit de réclamation auprès des
autorités de protection des données
l'adoption de ce critère conduirait à ce
que des citoyens français soit obligé de
s'adresser par exemple un organisme de
protection irlandais pour toutes
contestations relatives au site internet
d'une entreprise dont le principal
établissement se trouverait en irlande
que la cnil ne puisse pas faire
prévaloir la loi française en dehors du
territoire français est une chose mais
qu'on empêche d'intervenir lorsque la
protection de la vie privée de citoyens
français est en cause en est une autre
cette évolution ne va clairement pas
dans le bon sens si l'on veut
véritablement privilégier l'intérêt du
citoyen on ne peut pas conserver le
critère du principal établissement pour
déterminer la compétence des autorités
de protection en matière de données à
caractère personnel
en outre contrairement à l'opinion
exprimée par madame reding
le gouvernement regrette qu'au nom de l'
objectif certes louable de
simplification de la vie des entreprises
et de développement du marché intérieur
les fichiers de face même plus dans un
grand nombre de cas l'objet d'une simple
déclaration à la cnil avant alors mise
en oeuvre ceci reviendrait à priver la
crds il d'une source précieuse
d'information et amenuisent sa capacité
à orienter au mieux ces contrôles
s'agissant de la création d'un droit à
l'oubli numérique
le gouvernement souhaite il n'y ait
aucune ambiguïté ce droit à l'oubli
n'est certes pas expressément consacré
dans notre droit
mais la loi informatique et libertés a
prévu des mécanismes tels le droit
d'opposition et le droit de
rectification ou d'effacement des
données qui concerne une personne y
compris sur internet
cette loi permet également à cnil dont
je me rappelle des effectifs et des
moyens budgétaires ont été renforcés de
sanctionner tous responsables de
traitement qui méconnaîtraient lé droit
d'opposition de rectification et de
suppression des personnes sont dans
données personnelles au delà et des
pétitions de principe sur la
proclamation d'un nouveau droit il
convient surtout de rechercher
l'effectivité dans le contexte
d'internet
le projet de règlement grand ducal blick
par la commission européenne confère aux
internautes un droit effectif à l'oubli
numérique dans l'environnement en ligne
c'est à dire le droit à faire effacer
les données les concernant
s'ils retirent leur consentement et si
aucun autre motif légitime ne justifie
la conservation de celle ci toutefois
madame reding a reconnu que de nombreux
experts etc
rieur à la commission européenne
doutaient de l'application effective de
cette disposition
selon eux ce droit serait techniquement
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement veillera
à ce que ces dispositions qui doivent
être soutenus ne se traduisent pas
paradoxalement par un recul des droits
des personnes en dehors de la sphère
numérique
enfin le gouvernement est très réservée
quant à l'obligation de désigner
systématiquement un délégué à la
protection des données au sein des
structures publiques ou privées nous
estimons que la mise en place de tels
délégué de demeurer facultative en effet
le succès des correspondants à la
protection des données prévue par la loi
depuis 2004 repose précisément sur le
caractère facultatif de l'an désignation
il est seule de nature à favoriser la
diffusion de la culture de la protection
des données dans un esprit de confiance
la logique de contraint risquerait
d'être contre-productive en conséquence
le projet de règlement proposé par la
commission devra faire l'objet de
modifications importantes afin de
garantir la meilleure protection de nos
concitoyens vous avez cieux les
sénateurs la loi du 6 janvier 1978
relative à l'informatique aux fichiers
et aux libertés est devenu être un
développement spectaculaire du monde
numérique une loi fondamentale pour la
protection des droits de nos concitoyens
c'est en respectant l'équilibré qu'elle
a su trouver entre la protection de la
vie privée et le libre développement du
traitement des données que nous ferons
face aux défis que représentent les
soeurs de l'outil numérique
c'est dans cet esprit que le
gouvernement français participent
activement aux travaux en cours au
niveau européen travaux auxquels bien
entendu seront associés et des
parlementaires
et je veux dire au sénat du
particulièrement où deux présidents qui
sont ici et que le gouvernement apprécie
la résolution qui nous est proposé qui
la prends comme une incitation à
continuer dans la voie à laquelle il
s'est engagé pour que nous puissions
assurer la meilleure des protections à
nos concitoyens dans ce domaine si
sensible
qui nous échappe tellement à la fois des
données personnelles et de la révolution
numérique permanente je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame nicole borvo
cohen seat pour le groupe crc ce
président ce ministre chers collègues
aujourd'hui le techniquement la
possibilité de collecter des données
personnelles ne cesse de croître
et cela sans que l'on en soit forcément
conscient tout individu susceptible
d'être fiché ceci à son insu tout au
long de sa vie à simple mise en oeuvre
de moyens techniques lors de ses
déplacements connexion consultation
d'informations transaction qui plus est
depuis une dizaine d'années la lutte
contre l'insécurité le terrorisme et
l'immigration sont devenus des éléments
de justification commode au fichage en
tous genres au mépris des libertés
individuelles et publiques dans le
respect est pourtant au coeur de la
démocratie ainsi que nous avons eu
l'occasion de le dénoncer à plusieurs
reprises on assiste désormais à la mise
en oeuvre d'une surveillance policière
doublé d'un contrôle social généralisé
de la population
ce fichage tentaculaire touchent aussi
bien l'éducation nationale les
bénéficiaires d'allocations sociales des
consommateurs les clients des banques et
assurances les personnes nationalité
étrangère celles placées sous main de
justice ou encore celle suivi en
psychiatrie
dans le même temps le développement des
réseaux sociaux à favoriser la mise à
disposition volontaires d'informations
personnelles et sans que l'on puisse
réellement connaître et maîtriser
l'usagé qui en est fait nous décider de
son retrait ultérieur
les fichiers informatiques et les
traitement automatisé de données à
caractère personnel qui sont associés
sont ainsi devenus de véritables outils
de gestion de la société
en même temps que de formidable manne
financière par la commercialisation de
façon occulte et accéléré de ces données
à des entreprises désireuses de cibler
leurs offres publicité
l'adoption il ya 17 ans de la directive
européenne 95 46 relative à la
protection des personnes physiques à
l'égard du traitement des données à
caractère personnel et à la libre
circulation de ces données fut l'acte
fondateur de la protection de la vie
privée à l'échelle communautaire et sa
modernisation semble désormais à la fois
urgente et indispensable
la commission européenne a fait le choix
de réviser la directive européenne de 95
par l'intermédiaire de deux instruments
juridiques distincts leurs instruments
est une directive spécifique traitant
des questions relevant de l'ex troisième
pilier communautaires relatifs au
secteur police on peut regretter qu'il
ait été choisi d'instaurer des règles
spécifiques en matière de coopération
policière et judiciaire en matière
pénale les mêmes dispositions devraient
au contraire s'appliquer cela est autant
plus nécessaire dans un contexte de
multiplication des fichiers en matière
policière et judiciaire
lors de la transposition de cette
directive nous devrons donc veiller à ce
que les règles applicables aux questions
police justice ne soit pas moins
protectrices que celle prévue par la
proposition de règlement européen qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui
s'agissant ce règlement il consacre de
nouveaux droits pour l'ensemble des
citoyens européens tels que le droit à
l'oubli ou l'encadrement des règles de
recueil du consentement qui sont une
réelle avancée constitue un bon point de
départ pour l'adoption des règles
européennes sur la protection des
données nous permettant de faire face
aux défis des technologies informatiques
néanmoins notre collègue simon sutour à
formuler quelques critiques que nous
partageons bien la proposition de
résolution présentée aujourd'hui
l'idée n'est pas de critiquer l'ensemble
du texte qui apporte de vraies avancées
attendues nécessaire de mettre le doigt
sur les dispositions qui posent problème
et qui mériteront d'être corrigé alors
que les autorités de protection sont
aujourd'hui compétente pour l'ensemble
des traitements réalisés sur le
territoire de leur état la proposition
de règlement prévoit l'introduction du
critère de l'établissement principal qui
donne compétence à l'autorité du pays
dans lequel est établie établissement
principal de ce responsable de
traitement
ce système aboutira nécessairement un
éloignement considérable des citoyens
des autorités de protection compétentes
sans compter qu'ils risquent de
favoriser la pratique du forum shopping
et de créer une concurrence extra
communautaires entre états membres
intracommunautaire pardon entre états
membres
la proposition de règlement confère à la
seule commission européenne le pouvoir
de déterminer de préciser les conditions
d'application concrète tant juridique
que technique des dispositions et des
droits nouveaux le système proposé lui
confère des pouvoirs normatifs très
important et limite fortement le rôle
des autorités nationales comme cela a
déjà dit en aboutissant à une
centralisation des pouvoirs entre les
mains de la commission
cela porte atteinte au principe de
subsidiarité et nous pensons qu'il est
plus efficace de ventiler ce pouvoir
normatif et laisser aux autorités
nationales les soins de prévoir certains
actes concernant le droit à l'oubli nous
regrettons tout comme l'a formulé la
cnil le manque d'ambition dont a fait
preuve la commission en n'incluant pas
la possibilité d'obtenir des
référencements d'une donnée à caractère
personnel sur les moteurs de recherche
qui ne sont pas concernés par ce nouveau
droit proposée par la commission
européenne
la proposition de résolution entend
pallier ses lacunes en souhaitant un
renforcement du droit à l'oubli des
obligations pesant sur les moteurs de
recherche
en souhaitant que l'adresse ip soit
traitée comme une donnée personnelle que
le règlement ne prive pas les états
membres d'adopter une législation plus
protectrice ou encore qu'en cas de
problème le citoyen traite avec
l'autorité nationale compétente
ainsi la multiplication des fichiers
informatiques et l'augmentation de la
durée de conservation des données qui
sont aussi nié l'élargissement des
personnes habilitées à les consulter
la multiplication des interconnexions de
fichier constitue autant d'atteintes aux
libertés auxquelles il convient de
mettre un terme
la révision de la directive de 1995 est
ainsi nécessaire mais la proposition de
règlement assortie d'une directive
européenne sont ils suffisants nous ne
pouvons qu en douter
quand la directive créer des mesures
dérogatoires pour les fichiers les plus
sensibles policier et judiciaire
nous aurons l'occasion de nous exprimer
sur ce sujet ultérieurement
en attendant nous sommes évidemment
favorables à la proposition de
résolution présentée aujourd'hui qui va
dans le sens souhaité celui d'un
accroissement de la protection des
données personnelles
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
anne marie escoffier pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
monsieur le président monsieur pardonnez
moi monsieur le garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice et des libertés
monsieur président de la commission des
lois monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre me pardonnerez vous
ce brin de coquetterie à votre endroit
des coups monsieur le ministre me
pardonnerez vous ce brin de coquetterie
à votre endroit nous vous nous nous
réjouissions de vous voir revenu au banc
du gouvernement pour la quatrième fois
en moins de deux ans sur ce sujet de la
protection des données personnelles des
citoyens et cela d'autant plus que le
c'est le sénat qui est à l'initiative de
ces questionnements successifs sur une
question que personne ne peut plus et ne
veut plus éluder pourrait-on imaginer
quelques frilosité de la part du
ministre de la justice et des libertés
un ministre garant justement de la
liberté des citoyens dans un domaine ou
l'enfermement subi voir auto créé
devient la banalité du quotidien
nous avons été nombreux sur ses travées
un peu proto probablement mais c'est
tout le problème des précurseurs a
relevé les dangers qui insidieusement
s'infiltre dans notre vie privée des
dangers liés comme toujours au progrès
mais je ne dis ces retraits pas sur le
paradoxe vieux comme le monde des effets
négatifs et parfois destructeurs du
progrès j'évoquerai al'inverse d'autres
progrès liés à l'impact
omniprésent des nouvelles technologies
de la vidéoprotection de la
géolocalisation de la radio
identification des nanotechnologies qui
tous les jours piège un peu plus l'homme
et pousse la puissance publique à 6
mixer dans la sphère privée
la puissance publique il ne s'agit pas
seulement de la france pas seulement de
l'europe ni même des états unis
tous les pays sont concernés et les
exemples sont nombreux pour montrer que
partout dans le monde les états
cherchent à maîtriser ses nouveaux
phenom
qui donne accès aux données personnelles
alors oui monsieur le ministre comment
une fois encore ne pas dire notre
incompréhension face à l'attitude du
gouvernement qui n'a pas permis à la
proposition de loi adoptée à l'unanimité
ici dont yves detraigne et moi et ça a
été rappelée étions coauteur et
christian cointat rapporteur comment
donc le gouvernement n'a pas permis que
ce texte certes amendable fasse son
chemin et préparer efficacement la
révision de la directive européenne du
24 octobre 1995
nous avons été par manque de réactivité
parce que nous n'avons pas osé être
précurseur parce que probablement aussi
nous booste publions quelques intérêts
particuliers
nous avons donc été rattrapé par la
commission européenne
elle a donc pris l'initiative de
refondre le cadre juridique de cette
directive
un cadre qui en tout état de cause
c'était prévu devait être modifié pour
tenir compte de l'évolution du contexte
mais qu'il a fait au détriment de notre
logique française dans une conception
européenne beaucoup moins protectrices
que celle dont nous bénéficions sous
l'autorité de la cnil
l'assemblée nationale a bien voulu
relever les dangers de la modification
proposée et a adopté une résolution de
notre collègue gosselin qui a eu l'heur
d'être entendu lui par le gouvernement
nous revenons donc aujourd'hui au sénat
avec cette même résolution pour dire à
notre tour nos divergences d'analysé par
rapport à la proposition de règlement
élaboré sous l'autorité de madame
viviane reding commissaire européen en
charge de la justice et des droits
fondamentaux
nous soutenons contrairement à ce
qu'elle a proposé que l'unification du
cadre juridique européen ne doit pas
avoir pour conséquence de faire reculer
le niveau de protection des états comme
l'état français disposant d'une
législation plus protectrice la
résolution demande donc au gouvernement
de veiller à ce que les états puissent
adopter d
dispositions plus favorables nous
redoutons les effets d'une nouvelle
gouvernance dès que proposait qui
affaiblirait le pouvoir de contrôle des
autorités nationales et des porterait la
régulation des systèmes vers les pays
siègent des entreprises un tel
dispositif serait un mauvais coup pour
la france affaiblit dans son pouvoir
décisionnel par rapport à des
entreprises installées le plus souvent
hors de notre territoire
ayant choisi l'irlande ou l'europe du
nord par exemple dans pareil cas les
citoyens se verrait privé d'un droit de
recours effectif et placerait
paradoxalement les entreprises dans une
situation plus favorable que les
citoyens de plus un tel critère
obligerait l'autorité nationale de
contrôle dans le ressort de laquelle est
placé le siège de l'entreprise à devoir
interpréter les législations d'autres
états dans des domaines aussi complexe
que le droit du travail ou le droit de
famille dès lors qu'elle serait saisi
par un citoyen d'un autre état nous ne
pouvons dans ces conditions qu adhérer à
la proposition de résolution qui tend
vers la restauration du pouvoir de
contrôle des autorités disposant alors
des moyens d'investigation nécessaire à
leurs missions de cette résolution qui
complète le régime de protection des
données personnelles en permettant la
désindexation des données sur les
moteurs de recherche en faisant et c'est
pour nous un point tout à fait essentiel
de l'adresse ip une véritable données
personnelles qui renforce enfin les
obligations pesant sur les responsables
de traitement en matière de transferts
internationaux de données
le groupe rds eu le groupe r d est ce
même si mais j'ai entendu les arguments
de mon collègue du touret je crois que
je vais faiblir
le groupe r dl ce même s'il regrette de
ne pas avoir été suivis sur une
proposition d'amendement qui cherche à
toujours mieux protéger les droits des
personnes en fonction des technologies
existantes
tiens à apporter tout son soutien à
cette proposition de résolution que vous
soutenez monsieur le ministre et nous
nous en réjouissons
pour faire barrage à un dispositif dont
ils prédisent
et lui le groupe rds depuis longtemps
qu'il ne serait favorable ni à la cnil
ni à la france merci ma chère collègue
la parole à monsieur jean bizet pour le
groupe ump pour dix minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues la
protection de la vie privée et des
données personnelles de nos concitoyens
représente depuis de longues années un
enjeu majeur de politique publique dans
notre pays la france a été un des
premiers pays au monde à se doter d'une
autorité de contrôle indépendante avec
l'adoption de la cnil dès 1978 et je
voudrais à ce moment saluer votre
engagement social des ministres sur
précisément le latitude que vous avez eu
à l'adresse de la cnil récemment vous
n'avez conforter à à plus d'un titre
et on peut dire que la législation
communautaire qui s'est mise en place
ensuite à été fortement inspirée par
l'exemple français
le soc de la législation communautaire
en matière de protection des données est
constitué par la directive européenne du
24 octobre 95
mais aujourd'hui ce texte est devenu
obsolète
en effet l'apparition d'internet
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux
l'utilisation de nouvelles technologies
et de nouvelles pratiques ont
considérablement transformé le monde du
numérique depuis l'adoption de la
directive en 1995 les données
personnelles des citoyens sont désormais
traités par différents acteurs
différents acteurs publics et privés au
niveau international et non plus
seulement dans un cadre national
les 250 millions d'internautes européens
utilisent de manière massive les réseaux
sociaux et les réseaux de stockage à
distance de données les données à
caractère personnel sont exploitées par
les entreprises est précieuse pour leur
activité économique
c'est dans ce contexte en forte
évolution que la commission européenne a
fait de la révision de ce cadre
juridique européen une priorité
stratégique de son action avec pour
objectif premier l'harmonisation et la
simplification des règles applicables en
europe
l'entrée en vigueur du traité de
lisbonne le 1er décembre 2010
a donné force contraignante à la charte
des droits fondamentaux qui dispose en
son article 8 que toute personne a droit
à la protection des données à caractère
personnel la concernant
par ailleurs le nouvel article 16 du
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'union
européenne définit les règles d'adoption
des textes européens permettant de
garantir le droit à la protection des
données personnelles
par ailleurs le programme de stockholm
et en avant le besoin pour l'union de
disposer d'un régime complet de
protection des données personnelles
conformément au traité la commission
européenne a donc déposé une proposition
de règlement tendant à remplacer la
directive de 1995 et instituant un cadre
général de l'union en matière de
protection des données ainsi qu'une
proposition de directive qui
remplacerait la décision-cadre de 2008
relative à la protection des données
traitées à des fins de prévention et de
détection des infractions pénales
denquête et poursuite en la matière
ainsi que d'activités judiciaire
connexes la proposition de résolution
européenne que nous examinons
aujourd'hui ne concerne que la réforme
de la directive du 24 octobre 1995
je ne reviens pas sur le fond qui a déjà
été parfaitement exposés par notre
rapporteur simon sutour je pense comme
lui qu'il convient de prendre acte des
avancées que recèle la proposition de
règlement européen sur la protection des
données personnelles
même si des améliorations peuvent être
apportées à notre avis il reste encore
beaucoup à faire
la commission des lois rejointe par la
commission des affaires européennes
estime que le dispositif proposé pose
deux problèmes sur lequel elle souhaite
attirer l'attention du gouvernement
l'une sur la nécessité laisser aux
législateurs nationale d'adopter des
mesures plus protectrices que le
règlement européen et l'autre sur
l'autorité de contrôle compétentes pour
assurer le respect des droits des
ressortissants d'un état membre
nous ne pouvons que donné notre accord à
ces deux remarques
premièrement parce que l'on ne peut pas
raisonnablement priver les états membres
de la possibilité d'adopter des
dispositions nationales plus
protectrices des droits individuels
l'harmonisation proposé ne doit se faire
par le bas si j'ose dire
elle ne doit se faire que dans le sens
d'une meilleure protection des personnes
autre remarque sur ce point la
commission européenne a choisi de
proposer un règlement en lieu et place
donc de la directive du 24 octobre 1995
applicables aux traiter des données
personnelles
on peut s'interroger sur l'opportunité
de retenir un texte d'application
directe alors que la législation
française la plus ancienne en la matière
dans les pays de l'union européenne est
bien souvent plus protectrices que celle
de nos partenaires
deuxièmement et ce point était
parfaitement soulevées par la commission
des affaires européennes
nous regrettons que dans la proposition
de règlement il y des renvois très
fréquent à des actes délégués ou à des
actes d'exécution de la commission
européenne pour préciser les modalités
d'application du règlement ce renvoi
massif à la législation délégués dans un
tel domaine nous paraît très critiquable
cela montre qu'il est nécessaire d'y
apporter des précisions voir des
garanties nouvelles serait préférable
que certaines questions soient réglés
directement par le législateur européen
les modalités du droit à l'oubli
numérique par excellence d'un point sur
lequel j'avais été assez sensible à cet
égard ce droit à l'oubli numérique doit
surtout être effectif et pas simplement
consacré et sur ce point je pense que le
gouvernement peut jouer un rôle beaucoup
plus important j'avoue que lorsque nous
avons auditionné la commissaire madame
reding en charge de ce dossier je n'ai
pas senti une volonté très ferme de sa
part que me suis permis de lui adresser
un courrier dans les jours qui ont suivi
et j'attends beaucoup de cette
résolution qui invite le gouvernement
être furent ce point pas excessivement
je dirais audacieux
troisième point j'avais même je me
permets l'occasion dit que moteur de
recherche le plus je dirais en vogue sur
cette planète
même si c'est techniquement par été
difficile mais à ce moteur de recherche
a rien d'impossible
troisième point que je souhaite
rapidement évoqué le dispositif du
guichet unique
je crois que la tension d'acn il a été
particulièrement focalisé sur ce point
non sans raison à mon avis le dispositif
prévu par le projet de texte européen
attribue la compétence pour instruire
les requêtes des citoyens européens à
l'autorité de contrôle du pays dans
lequel le responsable de traitement en
cause possède son principal
établissement
je crois qu'il s'agit d'un problème
important car il ya de fortes chances
que le citoyen soit renvoyé à l'autorité
de contrôle d'un autre pays
paradoxalement le citoyen serait moins
bien traités que le responsable du
traitement qui aurait lui un
interlocuteur unique
les aménagements prévus par la
commission européenne ne nous paraissent
pas suffisant et il est important à nos
yeux de garantir à nos concitoyens une
gestion de proximité de sa plainte
retenir la compétence de l'autorité de
l'état membre où réside le plaignant me
semble donc une bonne solution
je sais monsieur garde des sceaux que
vous avez déclaré ici même votre
opposition principaux critères du
principal établissement
il n'est pas normal que la cnil souhaite
écarter ou empêcher d'intervenir au nom
de l' harmonisation européenne alors
même que la protection de la vie privée
de citoyens français est en cause là va
précisément dans le bon sens
enfin je voudrais évoquer brièvement
l'encadrement des pouvoirs
d'investigation des autorités de
contrôle nationales que j'estime
beaucoup trop restrictif la référence un
motif raisonnable ne me convient pas
contenu compte tenu de la suppression
des formalités préalables reposant sur
les responsables de traitement
on peut considérer que ces
investigations constitue la principale
source d'information des autorités
nationales sur la mise en oeuvre des
traitements en conclusion la proposition
de résolution européenne adopté par la
commission des lois reconnaît clairement
que la proposition de règlement est
porteuse de
grosse avancée attendue est nécessaire
la protection de la vie privée des
citoyens est une question essentielle et
il est majeur de le garantir
à l'heure du numérique le gouvernement a
déjà fait beaucoup de choses et je
tenais à souligner je pense encore une
fois notamment renforcement considérable
des moyens de la cnhi je lui ai dit en
préambule et je le répète c'est au
niveau européen que la bataille pour la
protection des données personnelles se
situe essentiellement c'est la bataille
pour le respect de la vie privée de
chacun mais cette bataille ne peut pas
écarter les instances et les procédures
nationales surtout lorsque ces dernières
ont une antériorité une expérience et
une vraie compétence vous l'avez deviné
les préoccupations évoquées me
paraissent faire une large unanimité
dans nos rangs et le groupe ump votera
cette proposition de résolution sans
aucune retenue j'aurais souhaité ça
c'est mon clin d'oeil à l'ensemble de
nos collègues socialistes communistes et
écologistes sauf à notre collègue gâteau
la dame leila aichi j'aurais souhaité un
peu plus un peu plus d'attention un
petit peu plus de hauteur de vue un peu
plus de hauteur de vue de nos collègues
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'intérêt de nos
concitoyens de l'intérêt notre pays je
veux faire référence bien évidemment à
votre vote vous votre absence de vote
lors du débat sur le mécanisme européen
je dirais de stabilité puissiez vous mes
chers collègues vous en souvenir
merci
merci mon cher collègue la parole à
andré gattolin pour le groupe écologiste
pour six minutes
l'espoir
la parole a reçu gâteau la merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
chers collègues la protection des
données personnelles il faut le rappeler
est un droit reconnu au plus haut niveau
de la législation communautaire
elle est consacrée par l'article 16 du
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'union
européenne et par l'article 8 de la
charte des droits fondamentaux
dans le même temps son application
concrète repose sur une directive qui
date de 1995 et qui paraît malgré ses 17
ans à peine bien nagé il est vrai que
une révolution je dirais technologique
s'est produite mais pas simplement une
révolution technologique mais une
révolution aussi sociologique et
économique qui a bousculé l'ordre des
choses notamment à travers les nouvelles
technologies de l'information internet
développement des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui les bases de données peut
être totalement des méta dématérialisée
elle secret en permanence s'échangent en
une fraction de seconde franchise des
frontières très très rapidement les
internautes eux mêmes souvent sans s'en
rendre compte
nourrissent cette dynamique les premiers
internautes justement les premiers
utilisateurs d'internet étaient surtout
des consommateurs de données ils
allaient sur internet pour y trouver des
informations
il accepte désormais au statut de
producteur de données car il passe une
bonne partie de leur temps à écrire et à
diffuser des informations sur eux mêmes
et sur les autres a laissé plus ou moins
volontairement une multitude de traces
qui permettent de dessiner leur portrait
et qui font la fortune de certaines
entreprises parfois comme jeudi
en tout état de cause parfois à l'insu
de leur plein gré une revue française il
ya quelques années il y a trois ans qui
s'appelle le tigre s'était amusé à
dresser le portrait très détaillées dans
l'inconnu mais dans l'inconnu existant
réellement certain marco elle
à partir des uniquement des informations
que ce dernier avait rendu disponible
sur internet parfois en connaissance de
cause souvent sans le savoir le résultat
quand on lit cet article est absolument
édifiant et là l'auteur de l'article
lui-même la personne qui a fait la
compilation de ce portrait parle même
d'un portrait violemment impudique et
c'est toute sa vie qui est ainsi pu être
mis à jour
simplement par simple recoupement de
données par un tiers aujourd'hui de
nouveaux logiciels se met en place très
élaborés et il fonctionne donc ils ne
demandent qu'à être exploitées dans
l'univers numérique de logiciels de
reconnaissance visuelle c'est à dire une
photographie de vous en premier plan au
second plan sur une diffusée sur
internet peu par calcul sur des bases de
données être assimilé avec une assez
grande fiabilité à son auteur vous
imaginez effectivement tout ce que cela
peut signifier et tout ce que cela
nécessite
en matière de droit de nouvelles
protections pour que ces usages ne
devienne pas encore plus attentatoire à
la vie privée des personnes et c'est
d'ailleurs dans ce contexte que la
commission européenne a présenté leur
colle règlement qui examine la
proposition de résolution déposée par
notre collègue simon 6 tours proposition
de résolution évidemment pour laquelle
les écologistes voteront parce que elle
fait l'unanimité effectivement de nos
commissions et qu' elle va dans le bon
sens
et elle souligne à la fois le travail
qui a été fait pour actualiser la
directive de 95 qui devenait de plus en
plus souffrante mais en même temps cette
proposition de résolution point de
nombreux problèmes en dépit de ces
avancées notables qu'il se pose encore
aujourd'hui dans le texte présenté donc
par les représentants de la commission
alors il y en a un certain nombre les a
tous évoqués notamment il ya une chose
très positif c'est effectivement de le
faire d'établir dans l'entrée pour la
première fois du droit communautaire
le droit à l'oubli numérique cela a été
dit
en bien des points ça manque encore de
précision et surtout de la manière dont
on peut faire respecter cet oubli
numérique et ça mériterait d'être plus
profondément approfondie alors
effectivement comme cela était aussi
soulignée par plusieurs des orateurs et
notamment le rapporteur est aussi le
président de la commission des lois
il y à un renvoi et par monsieur le
ministre ni un renvoi dans ce texte
excessif bras de futurs actes délégués
ou actes d'exécution qui au passage sont
non seulement discutable mais prive les
parlements de l'exposé de l'examen de
ces dispositions
alors que règlement par définition est
d'application directe et que ça pose
effectivement un sérieux problème quand
on voit l'incertitude et de flou qui
règne sur beaucoup des points proposés
alors le problème du guichet unique a
déjà été évoquée donc je ne reviendrai
pas sur cette question mais il y a un
autre point qui a peu été soulevée dans
nos débats
le ministre en a parlé nous différons je
pense là dessus sur la proche et en ce
qui concerne la volonté de la commission
européenne dans son texte de contraindre
les entreprises de plus de 250 salariés
à se doter d'un délégué à la protection
des données
celui ci donc serez chargé de veiller en
interne au respect de la loi et
d'assurer la surface de l'interface avec
les autorités les consommateurs alors je
comprends bien
si chaque entreprise de 250 salariés
doit avoir ce type de représentants
c'est quelque chose de relativement
lourd néanmoins je trouve ce seuil
aberrant et stupide et nos
correspondants aucune connaissance
aujourd'hui de ce qu'est la réalité du
monde de l'entreprise numérique
je veux dire par là aujourd'hui les
entreprises qui gèrent des fichiers qui
gère des fichiers de données
personnelles font souvent loin
d'atteindre les 250 ce sont des
entreprises spécialisées parfois ce sont
des start up
elles sont subdivise à bhl et par la
sous traitance à volonté il faudrait
bien définir au moins un secteur celle
effective
en gérant des gros volumes de traitement
je rappelle par exemple une société
mondialement connus comme twitter qui
rassemble des les dvd des millions
aujourd'hui d'usagé ne compte à l'heure
actuelle que 700 salariés il est encore
un an et demi il n'y avait moins de 250
salariés donc on exclure et twitter et
certaines pme pmi faisant un usage
limité des données se verrait contrainte
donc il ya beaucoup de travail en
conclusion à faire c'est pour toutes ces
raisons et encore d'autres que le temps
ne nous permettent pas d'évoquer que il
nous semble indispensable que le
commission européenne revoie sa copie
apporte des précisions ou les
adaptations nécessaires pour être plus
opérantes en matière de protection de la
vie privée
merci mon cher collègue la parole à me
suivre de treignes pour le groupe union
centriste et républicaine pour sept
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur mis ses
chers collègues il y a deux en mars 2010
notre assemblée a adopté à l'unanimité
la proposition de loi déjà évoqué
déposée par anne marie escoffier et
moi-même qui visait à mieux garantir le
droit à la vie privée à l'heure du
numérique
cette proposition de loi prévoit y est
notamment de faire de la dre site est
une donnée personnelle de rendre
obligatoire la désignation d'un
correspondant informatique et libertés
dans les entreprises publiques ou
privées où plus de 100 personnes ont
accès à un fichier informatique étant
précisé qu'il était proposé que ce
correspondant puisse être mutualisé en
croit plusieurs entreprises pour nous
proposions également de rendre
obligatoire plus clair et plus
accessible l'information sur la durée de
conservation des données et la
possibilité pour les personnes
concernées d'exercer plus facilement
leur droit de suppression et de
rectification de mieux encadrer la
création et l'interconnexion des
fichiers de police de renforcer les
pouvoirs d'enquêté et de sanction de la
cnil bref si je puis dire de rendre plus
transparente et accessible aux
utilisateurs d'internet et autres
traitements numérique
les informations les concernant et de
donner en fait une sorte de réalité au
fameux droit à l'oubli
cette proposition de loi qui avait été
adoptée à l'unanimité sur le rapport et
avec les améliorations proposées par
notre collègue christian cointat up
était la fuite d'un rapport datant de
mai 2009 qui avait formulé une quinzaine
de recommandations pour mieux garantir
le droit à la vie privée à l'heure des
nouvelles mémoires numériques et
renforcer ainsi car c'est bien de cela
qu'il s'agit
la confiance des citoyens à l'égard de
la société de l'information
depuis que le sénat débattu de cette
question sont que malheureusement
l'assemblée nationale ne la reprenne à
son compte la qualité n'a eu de cesse de
démontrer l'urgente nécessité de
légiférer dans ce domaine on ne compte
plus les exemples de salariés victimes
dans leur entreprise de messages
électroniques échangés sur le net où
deux candidats à l'embauché qui se voit
opposer par leurs futurs employeurs des
informations d'ordre privé
qu'ils croyaient n'avoir transmis qu'à
leurs amis mais qui était de fait devenu
très rapidement accessible au plus grand
nombre
sans compter les systèmes illégaux de
croisement de fichiers qui peuvent
permettre parfois à une entreprise
d'espionner ses salariés comme la presse
sont de fait l'écho il ya moins d'une
semaine
on ne peut donc que se réjouir de voir
la commission européenne s'emparer de
cette question qui touche à nos libertés
fondamentales et publiée le 25 janvier
dernier d'une part une proposition de
règlement relatif à la protection des
personnes physiques à l'égard du
traitement des données à caractère
personnel et à la libre circulation de
ces données ainsi que d'autre part une
proposition de directive dont nous ne
parlons pas en réalité aujourd'hui
je ne vais pas reprendre toutes les
dispositions ni de la proposition de
règlement de la commission européenne ni
de la proposition de résolution préparé
par notre collègue simon sutour dont je
veux souligner la forte implication et
la sagacité sur un sujet qui il faut
bien le dire concernent énormément de
monde mais chapeau en réalité au plus
grand nombre mais en mettant notamment
en place un corpus commun de règles
relatives à la protection des données
applicable dans toute l'union européenne
en imposant davantage d'obligations aux
entités procédant aux traitements de
données à caractère personnel comme par
exemple l'obligation de notifier à
l'autorité de contrôle nationales les
violations graves de ces données en
prévoyant que chaque fois que le
consentement de l'individu concerné est
exigé pour que ces données puissent être
traitées et bien ce consentement ne soit
plus présumés mais soit expressément
donné en facilitant l'accès des
personnes concernées à leurs propres
données en instaurant un droit à l'oubli
numérique pouvant permettre aux citoyens
d'obtenir la suppression des
informations les concernant si aucun
motif valable ne justifient leur
conservation et en prévoyons que les
règles européennes devront aussi
s'appliquer pour des traitements est
réalisée à l'étranger par des autres par
des entreprises implantées sur le mât
européens pour ne citer que ces quelques
exemples du contenu de la proposition de
règlement européen la proposition va
incontestablement dans le bon sens
certes elle recèle quelques lacunes et
la présentation qui en a qui en a été
faite par la commissaire européenne qui
insiste peu plus en tout cas c'est mon
sentiment sur la nécessité de donner un
coup d'accélérateur à l'économie
européenne et de réduire les contraintes
qui pèsent sur les entreprises que sur
la nécessité pourtant tout aussi
importante de protéger les libertés
individuelles peut nous alerter il ne
faudrait pas que paradoxalement en
voulant unifier le droit européen dans
le même de la protection des données
personnelles
on en vienne à compliquer les
possibilités d'intervention des
individus concernés et à affaiblir les
autorités de contrôle nationales qui
dans de nombreux pays dont le nôtre ont
su faire preuve depuis de nombreuses
années de clairvoyance et d' équilibre
il est donc tout à fait important pour
notre assemblée de le dire explicitement
ainsi que d'autres choses par cette
résolution
la commission des lois ayant repris les
amendements que proposait notre collègue
jean paul amoudry qui représente notre
assemblée je le rappelle au sein de la
cnil et qui connaît donc
particulièrement bien ces questions on
peut considérer c'est en tout cas mon
mon sentiment profond que la proposition
de résolution en tirant les conséquences
des interrogations soulevées notamment
lors de l'audition de madame reding et
qui n'ont pas toutes reçues réponse il
faut bien le dire constitue une feuille
de route je crois équilibré pour les
négociations que le gouvernement va
maintenant engager avec nos partenaires
européens sur le projet de règlement de
la commission européenne le groupe
centriste approuve donc la proposition
de résolution qui nous est soumise
merci merci mon cher collègue je vais
passer je vais passer la parole à
monsieur le garde des sceaux beaucoup
plus pollueurs de permettre de dire
quelques mots qui sont probablement des
sens personnel pour dire ma joie de voir
guy fischer avec nous ce soir
guy est un ami ancien fidèle de toujours
certain nombre de choses nous sépare
beaucoup nous rassemble nous partageons
des valeurs de partage et une action
commune et je suis heureux de te voir là
ce soit avec nous je veux redire tout
ton courage au courage admirable pendant
la maladie
ta force est aussitôt envie de vivre et
quito soutenu pendant tout ce temps
alors c'est vrai aujourd'hui c'est un
jour de joie pour moi
pour toutes celles et ceux qui ont
toujours compter sur toi pour les
déformant faire entendre leur voix et
que tu aimes et puis je peux dire aussi
que pour le gouvernement avoir
d'adversaire de la qualité de guy
fischer c'est une chance alors mon cher
à guy continue vas-y et c'est toujours
avec joie quand on verra ici
merci merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
j'ai moi même tout à l'heure au nom du
sénat 10 13 est très heureux de cette
que cette belle personnalité qui est guy
fischer soit là et je lui donne
immédiatement la parole comme je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure j'étais très heureux
que vous présidiez cette séance je
voudrais dire à monsieur le garde des
sceaux qui a été pendant très longtemps
le président du conseil et qu'il est
toujours d'ailleurs le président du
conseil général du rhône
combien nous avons au cours de 26 années
de conseil général ont pu tisser un
certain nombre de liens je représentais
l'opposition communiste au sein du
conseil général du rhône
mais il est vrai que à force et au fil
des années bien des qualités qui au-delà
bien sûr de nos sensibilités politiques
revient ont pu se développer ont pu
faire la réalité la richesse des hommes
et je voudrais en profiter pour
remercier tous les sénateurs et
sénatrices et je crois que tous les
bancs ont pu me témoigner durant cette
douloureuse épreuve
leur amitié leurs soucis va de me voir
réapparaître au sénat entre guillemets
et je dois dire que pour moi c'est une
joie donc de voir des sénatrices et
décéda tort beaucoup que je ne connais
pas son corps mais aussi et bien des
présidents comme jean pierre sueur qui
ont accédé à d'autres fonctions nous
avons cheminé ensemble mais pour nous
avec le groupe communiste et avec nicole
borvo ben nous serons toujours nous
feront toujours partie de cette
résistance à un certain nombre de au
cours d'un certain nombre de débats
mais monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie infiniment de l'amitié ainsi
que tous mes collègues sénatrices et
sénateurs qui m'ont témoigné bien dans
des douloureuses épreuves qu'ont subi
tous à un moment dans notre vie qui
m'ont témoigné de leur amitié
merci infiniment il est des moments dans
la vie d'un parlementaire qui sont des
moments qui comptent des moments
d'émotion dans ce moment politique la
plus grande confrontation nationale que
la france connaisse je crois que ce
moment de rassemblement d'amitié de
solidarité de fraternité mais remercie
monsieur le garde des sceaux d'y avoir
contribué
je pense que c'est important une belle
personnalité comme guy fischer qui
revient aujourd'hui symboliquement pour
la clôture de notre session cédé à
marquer je lui souhaite à mon tour une
nouvelle fois bon vent la parole est à
virginie klès pour le groupe socialiste
et apparentés pour sept minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues un moment
de consensus auquel bien évidemment je
m'associe en souhaitant aussi du haut de
cette tribune la bienvenue à notre
collègue licha et qu'ils ne s'inquiètent
pas on continuera aussi avec lui notre
travail d'opposition
chaque fois que ce sera nécessaire pour
autant aujourd'hui on est sur un texte
qui amène plutôt le consensus
effectivement cette proposition de
résolution de notre collègue ce tour
tente au nom de la commission européenne
que de la commission des lois sujet
important s'il en est que celui de la
protection des données privées à l'ère
du numérique
à l'ère où ça a été déjà souligné un
certain nombre de fois les technologies
finissent presque par aller plus vite
que l'esprit humain et peuvent
effectivement dans certains cas mettre
en danger la vie privée et le droit à la
vie privée et l'anonymat des personnes
alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous
discutons autour du règlement entoure la
proposition de règlement européen sur
les fichiers notamment commerciaux
sachant qu'un autre texte est aussi à
l'étude qui est un texte une directive
européenne qui concernera l les fichiers
souveraineté alors je sais bien que
quand on pense que quand on parle de
l'ain on ne parle pas des autres oudéa
ne parle pas des autres pour autant
j'aimerais quand même attiré l'attention
des membres du gouvernement et de mes
collègues du parlement sur ses sur ses
bancs sur la non séparation complète
entre ce qu'ils sont ce que sont les
fichiers de 10 de souveraineté et ses
fameuses fichiers commerciaux qui nous
occupe plus particulièrement aujourd'hui
pourquoi attirer votre attention des
ondes dès aujourd'hui sur le sujet parce
qu'il me semble nécessaire que le
parlement français fasse bloc autour de
ces sujets le faisons à peser dans les
négociations qui vont se mener ensuite
avec l'europe avec nos partenaires
européens
alors pourquoi est ce que je ne fais pas
une distinction si complète et totale
entre les fichiers de souveraineté et
les fichiers commerciaux
tout simplement parce qu'on ne serait ce
que les fichiers de cartes grises qui
sont bien des fichiers destinés à lutter
contre un certain nombre de
l'infraction visée de cartes qu'ils
peuvent être vendus par l'état à des
sociétés commerciales dans des
conditions certes encadré
mais pour autant dans des conditions
dans lesquelles je ne suis pas certaine
que chaque citoyen français est
réellement donner un consentement libre
express et éclairé et parfaitement
volontaire
ces fichiers de cartes grises sont
vendus à des sociétés pour lesquelles
l'état peut de façon assez
discrétionnaire demander des enquêtes
administratives sur lesquels l'état peut
demander des enquêtes administratives et
en fonction du résultat de ces enquêtes
administratives on sait pas très bien
sur quel critère accepter ou ne pas
accepter de vendre ses fichiers c'est là
me semble-t-il justement un lien fort
entre ces fichiers dits de souveraineté
et ses fichiers commerciaux partir du
moment où le fichier des cartes grises
ou des données personnelles incluses
dans ces fichiers de cartes grises sont
vendus à des garages ou à des sociétés
automobiles diverses et variées ces
fichiers tombe dans le domaine
commercial est temps que cette fois ci
sous le coup du règlement et non plus
directif il ya donc des liens étroits
entre les deux il me semble importante
de l'avoir en tête dès aujourd'hui et
quand on étudiera la directive de se
rappeler que nos fichiers de
souveraineté peuvent tomber dans le
domaine commercial de façon rapide
facile et en tout cas aujourd'hui en
toute légalité
ça me semble important aussi à
considérer puisque on n'aille pas il n'y
a pas si longtemps que ça nous avons
parlé dans cette enceinte et nous en
parlerons encore je l'espère parce que
j'espère que le combat n'est pas terminé
un combat qui n'est pas terminée en tout
cas c'est le fichier qui sera lié aux
cartes nationales d'identité biométrique
avec le lien fort le lien faible
il est important de protéger les données
très très récemment je parle même plus
là devant d'ailleurs qui empêchera
l'état demain peut-être de vendre un
certain nombre de données dans ce
fichier centralisé
de tous les français avec avec un lien
fort entre les données biométriques et
données biographiques aujourd'hui il ya
rien qui empêchera l'état français
éventuellement de vendre ce genre de
choses mais indépendamment même de la
vente
comment ces fichiers sont ils protégés
quand on voit déjà aujourd'hui certaines
entreprises qui récupère des données
dans les fichiers des cartes grises de
façon illégale dans d'autres fichiers
qui se les revendre entre elles vous
voyez bien que ce lien entre les
fichiers de souveraineté des fichiers
commerciaux
il existe il est là il est parfois légal
parfois illégales parfois sécurisé et
parfaitement sécurisé et nous devons
garder cet aspect des choses en tête
chaque fois que nous parlerons de
fichiers et de réglementation européenne
que ce soit directives ou règlement ça
me paraît vraiment primordial dans les
autres choses qui ont été déjà abordé
avant moi donc le consentement exprès et
éclairé me paraît particulièrement
importants et notamment ces notions de
notice ou d'informations qu'ils ne
deviennent pas un tel fatras et un tel
amas d'information dans un français
parfois approximatif parce que traduit
de façon approximative que plus personne
ne lit et je ne sais pas si grand nombre
d'entre vous ont lu jusqu'au bout les
acceptations de licences de certains
moteurs de recherche américain par
exemple où vous spécifie que vos données
privées sont conservés dans un pays
tiers de confiance mais de confiance
pour qui pour quoi sur la base de quoi
de quels critères personne n'en sait
rien ce n'est pas là un consentement
exprès et éclairé à mon sens il faudra
aussi être extrêmement attentif sur ce
genre de situation alors bien évidemment
on l'a tous dit aussi ici l'objectif des
textes qui nous sont soumis et
d'améliorer le niveau de protection des
données et en même temps aussi de
simplifier un certain nombre de
formalités notamment pour les
entreprises
personnellement qu'une entreprise voit
des formalités simplifiées
tant qu'on est sûr de la gestion interne
à l'entreprise qu'une entreprise
travaille en toute sécurité juridique me
paraît aussi une bonne chose qu'elle
sache précisément ce qu'elle a le droit
de faire ou de ne pas faire me paraît
une bonne chose mais mais je pense que
dès l'instant où pas actions de
l'entreprise
il y a des répercussions sur la vie
privée d'un particulier ou d'un citoyen
on ne peut plus la appliquer le droit du
siège de l'état de siège d'entreprise
mais on
bien appliquer le droit de l'état de
résidence du citoyen je veux vous réfère
à ce sujet un petit parallèle en matière
de droit du travail
quand disney s'installe à paris c'est
bien le droit du travail français qui
s'applique à paris même si en interne
entreprises fonctionnent avec sa culture
américaine dans ses procédés dans ses
processus etc
mais la gestion des citoyens fusse-t-il
français ou américain sur le sol
français relève bien du droit du travail
français et non pas du droit du travail
américain
une entreprise de vol aussi récemment à
fait le même genre de déconvenue en
france c'est bien le droit du travail
français qui s'applique à partir du
moment où on s'adresse aux citoyens les
propositions qui ont donc été émises
notamment par la cnil reprise par notre
collègue du tour de distinguer dansez
dansez dansez applications de droits
nationaux ou de droit femme nationaux de
résidence du citoyen ou de résidence de
l'entreprise de distinguer les choses
selon que l'on s'adresse à l'entreprise
ou selon que l'on s'adresse aux citoyens
me paraissent donc extrêmement
intéressant la notion d'état principal
se doit donc d'être nuancés selon les
sujets très précis dont on parle le
droit à l'oubli et sans doute aussi un
petit peu le grand oublié de la
proposition de texte que nous avons
aujourd'hui avec sa mine et non pas de
la résolution mais du texte européen
il faut insister auprès de l'europe
auprès de partenaires sur le
déréférencement des données clés excusez
moi monsieur président donc ce droit à
l'oubli me semble-t-il doit
impérativement être au coeur de nos
préoccupations
donc en conclusion bien évidemment nous
voterons la résolue sur notre collègue
sutour tout en étant conscient des
améliorations à apporter encore merci
c'est la fin de cette séance merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr très
belle journée à tous